do you have do you have pets I have
three cats upstairs we have seven we
have seven together we have four dogs
together what yeah cuz you know we used
to live here and she lives down the
street now so I I'm tonight I'm going to
go visit the dogs and hang out with her
so wait you have you have four dogs we
both we both do thank you and the four
dogs they're staying down this and then
you have the three cats here yeah yeah
ah it's better for the road for me with
cats yeah it's easier to maintain right
right but the dogs you have to walk them
and stuff are they are they mut mixes or
they are they broken they're all broken
they well no they were um cuz I Foster a
lot of dogs they were dogs that were
unadoptable either for Behavioral issues
but we love them I'm trying to get one
but my wife is we have one we have a
rescue from Aruba he's the best what
kind he's the best he's they actually
they call him a rubian kuko oh yeah yeah
so he's amazing but uh name it took him
no his name's Lloyd oh oh Lloyd is such
a cute his name Lloyd's the best I
thought you named aruan kuko like long
name come on Ruby kuko come
on aruby kuko I can't get inside
now I never heard
that uh but he he took a long time to
like get good like I'd be on the road in
Chicago my wife would go you got to get
a friend to get them because they're
like they run wild in Aruba and they're
killing like 200 of them a month in a
kill shelter because they're just
running so they found my dog and his
brother in a dumpster when they were 6
weeks old and they're beautiful so
people teamed up with people in New York
and Connecticut they tourists bring them
we have them at 18 months he turned to
the best but now I want I want a dog and
now I'm trying to get my wife and I
think she's gonna I think she's gonna go
but I want big and she wants small so
we're gonna meet halfway get a small
Smalls are so good I like to [__] around
with a you can [__] around with a small
one I like big and small yeah yeah I
wanted it I wanted a great thing but
they live they don't live here here I
want you to do this don't have anything
in mind whatever you see and feel in
your heart yeah that's the one yeah
maybe like a Cy Corso or something those
are no joke cilia Mastiff yeah you know
a lot yeah see yeah so so what really
hurt me is the uh the two cats the two
cats a real that you yeah the two cats
died [__] oh you had two cats they they
look like twins they died they they were
real brothers they died Stanley was on
the right he just went a few months ago
he was 18 and A2 and Thomas the one in
the middle he died at 16 and a half and
that [__] dude bringing them that really
[__] me up man that was the hardest
that was the hardest thing and then they
put me in a room with them and they let
me just hold them and they were like you
take the time and I'm like I don't know
and then she goes when you're ready just
ring the bell and we'll come in and I go
what were they dead already and I you
watch them go you when they're about to
be put down yeah before they put them
down you can go in and just kind of
spend time with them and dude dude I
can't even dude if and then I can't
even what I can't
[__] I got you
back say baby I thought that was out of
pocket but it
wasn't uh now Lloyd Lloyd is Lloyd is on
the left and he's seven and he's awesome
does he have a GPS tag on him no he's
got the it's because we have there's so
much land back there that he's has the
boundaries so but he's afraid of it so
it'll beep like 5 feet before he gets
there and he's even afraid of the beep
so he won't even he's all good just just
when he's in the oh he's so cute he's
the best yeah but what's let me ask you
something what why can't he go beyond
the boundaries because there's just too
many too many woods too many wild
animals what okay what is the a wild
animal in New York Woods that are scary
uh all right so my wife my wife's Garden
was completely ransacked by a bear and
the thing pulled the bars the thing
pulled open the bars like Hulk and went
in and [__] had a field day my God
[__] yeah it looked like a it looked
like a robbery and it just with so so we
don't want him you know but bears eat
dogs Bears will eat I mean the mother
will the Cubs won't but the mother sees
a dog [__] and coyotes in packs like if
you see one coyote they're afraid you
see multiple they'll kill your dog so
you know the coyotes here are they'll
just charge I mean like if they're if
you're they're actor
coyotes you're Lloyd Lloyd looks big
enough that the coyote probably won't
charge but if your dog is even like 25
pounds they'll come for you and then
they'll follow you like so when you I
hike a lot here with my smaller dogs and
just when I think I've passed a pack of
coyotes I'm like okay I'm safe you turn
around and they're sneaking up on behind
you I've had friends with leash dogs
lose their dogs to coyotes yeah we had
uh one like one night the weather was
getting crazy and all of these Hawks
were coming big hawks and they just
circle around cuz they're looking for
mice and they were actually looking at
cats they were looking at our cats but
our cats were too big
Thomas was like a 20 pounder like they
couldn't do but they they actually like
they contemplated like jannis was going
that thing is contemplating they look
wow yeah yeah well that's the reason why
we didn't end up buying that one house
there with Hawk alley yeah Hawk alley
yeah yeah cuz there was like a ton of
them there and our cats were Ming is so
small yeah but what if they're the fans
what do you mean what if what what what
the hul's like just think about this we
we
assume I'm not being this not a joke
okay right you assume these Hawks are
going to eat your cats what if he's like
I've never met a cat before like you
know I have a [__] uh raccoon friend
I see you know I have a field mouse
friend I I want to meet a cat but then
you know you got we look up there you
know with you know they try it if they
may be curious yeah that's what I'm
saying like inters species friendships
yeah I've seen it on YouTube all the
time dude true a lion with a [__]
duck hanging out my money's on there
hunting but all right the odds s right
the odds are they're hunting the odds
are okay all right right I don't think
he's going I want to hang out with that
[__] all right I'm just all I ask
question listen you know what I don't I
the mind I don't blame that you're good
for you I don't blame you for that
because I believe in things that people
think I'm nuts for yeah I don't want to
make assumptions like what like what
yeah all right yeah go ahead all right
don't [__] threaten me with a good
[__] conversation go
um you guys like go ahead what [__]
what